chief executive of one of the companies
behind the new tests
dna nudge chris welcome to you so
essentially this works by
the patient taking a swab and then it's
inserted into your equipment
yeah absolutely yes so um and this is
the uh
this is the cartridge it's effectively
an entire laboratory
in something not much bigger than say a
hewlett packard printer cartridge
we've miniaturized everything and and
and the beauty is that you can actually
now test take the test
to the patient rather than taking the
test
to the laboratory which takes a lot of
time
and it's pretty simple and
straightforward so effectively
what we do is we take something either
like a nasal swab but we're using a
pediatric swab
so this is very much a swab that you
would use
in a child and effectively you can
either swab part of your nasal
but the preferred route is to use a
saliva swap
and what we do is you can put the swab
into the mad
cells and then this goes into the
cartridge
you then pull out the swap from the
cartridge you
seal it and then the virus is contained
and that's the beauty now
contain the virus in the cartridge
and you get the results within 90
minutes yeah
so effectively what's happening is the
first step is just
to kill the virus you then extract the
dna from the virus
and the dna effectively like like fish
and we've got all these wells with all
the different gene bait if you like that
we're looking to detect
so once the fish has bitten the bait you
effectively then detect whether you've
got the virus or not and that takes
just over an hour because we have to
amplify that fish if you like to make it
big enough
to bite the bait that's all done in this
little shoe box type device
called a nudge box so effectively the
cartridge goes into the nudge box
you close the box and the reason
and the reason it takes around an hour
or so is because effectively every time
you heat and cool the dna
that's amplifying it and that's known as
pcr and that's all done
in this little portable box right so
yeah the idea is to really post a
patient
and the and the cartridges are they
reusable or they they only can be used
once
no they're disposable because obviously
we don't want to contaminate
in everything so once you've done the
test you throw them away
and how long has it taken you to develop
this capability
well actually we repurposed it from
something that we're using in retail
anyway for genetic testing the original
idea
was to not look at for the genes of the
virus but to look at human dna
and to test things like risks for
obesity and type 2 diabetes
which as you know are epidemic today
and effectively and then you can shop
with your dna we've got a wearable and
you can go and shop and
pre-covered we thought to ourselves well
actually if we take the same technology
and instead of putting
the bait for human dna why don't we put
the bait
for the viral rna and that's what we did
so it took us from the time we invented
it
for dna testing to the time that we're
using it now
for virus testing it took us about four
or five months of
flat out repurposing from about march up
until now
so it's been really really hard work
we've worked with the department of
health we've validated in
in major london hospitals particularly
saint mary's
also at the john radcliffe in oxford
we've got great
sensitivity and one of the important um
value-added functions is because we've
got so many wells
of many things we mentioned flu flu a
flu b
rsv but also we can look at human
dna which means we're testing the
adequacy of the swab
so if the swap was no good we would know
because we wouldn't get a result so it
would be an invalid
whereas in hospitals unfortunately they
don't have that control
and some of these results come back as
negative when really
the swab hasn't been adequate so that's
the beauty of a test like this with no
lab as well
and how much will it cost per test
roughly chris
so so at the moment i mean it's being
sold to
absolute factory cost to the nhs and
we're just talking a few tens of pounds
so so it's so it's really really really
and and as in scaling when you think of
the cost of you know hewlett packard
cartridges
and anything else that's sort of
miniaturized then the cost could go down
to a few dollars eventually
chris one more question if um if i'm
worried about my
data my dna data what happens to that
after the test is done does that get
maintained
by the authorities no no it gets
destroyed
the whole data gets destroyed because
effectively
actually there are these
direct-to-consumer companies where you
have to send your dna
off to a laboratory that's a slight
concern
because your genetic material is being
sent somewhere
whereas here the genetic material goes
into the cartridge and once the test is
finished
this gets disposed so we don't keep any
genetic material we just keep the result
of your genetic material which is the
most important thing that we need to
keep
all right chris that was an absolutely
fascinating demonstration really
appreciate you joining us thank you
you